well I'm gonna ask you a little bit
before we talk about the movie about
meeting the man and what that was like I
understand you got to see him work with
you see a memorable experience but
outside of the actual you know
actualities of what an autopsy is what
is his demeanor in the room and how does
he what is the respect that he shows
okay I guess he can't call him for
patience the cadavers with him with that
he's working with he deals with the dead
as his patients and I went to to see him
perform autopsies I saw about five
autopsies and because after I saw the
first one it would it would have been
nice to be finished with that but it was
such a part of who he who he is
he is first of all he's an absolutely
beautiful man and he he views himself as
the deliverer of souls from this realm
to the next and he sees that as his job
so when he's when he's performing an
autopsy it's there's music it's
beautiful he'll talk to the body he's
touching them you know and he is trying
to he's a deeply deeply religious and
and spiritual man and in in watching him
and spending that that time with him
that was my into the character that's
when I when I understood the level and
depth of his spirituality which is which
is an interesting contradiction with
science you know but that that was
really the core of who that that
beautiful man was does he still today
feel that in many ways meeting Mike
Webster was something that was bad for
him does he wish it never happened or
does he realize now that he had to do
the work that he had to do well the this
movie opens on Christmas so I think he's
okay at this point you know we're here
we're here you know which is which is an
interesting story and a story for a
Bennett this this is a man who grew up
in in Nigeria
and look to America part of the thing
that that you know compelled me to make
the movie in my first meeting with him
and we used it in the film when he said
as a boy growing up in Nigeria heaven
was here and America was here and he
said to him it was the place where God
sent all of his favorite people so for
me too well I mean he hasn't been
watching the news but Trump is elected
that's not going to happen he in in you
know in that meeting with him and
sitting and and talking with him about
that I got so deeply connected to him so
for this to be one of the points in his
story to be able to deliver his life in
his pain and his experiences in this you
know film outside of everything for me I
love being able to be a part of his life
in that way now ya know just an
interesting coda to Bennett is you know
when he married preman Pittsburgh before
all the star to happen he promised her
you know these were people from you know
rural Africa he promised her as part of
the American dream that he build her a
mansion so you see in the film he's
beginning to build her their dream house
and then of course the walls closed in
his life collapses he's exiled he's sent
away literally the day before they were
to move in they get on the plane and
leave Pittsburgh forever for California
and when I first met Bennett I went to
his house in Lodi and it's you know his
nice ranch house on the cul-de-sac and
interestingly just to answer your
question is from this movie he finally
bought her their dream house and a big
nice big house still in Lodi we finally
moved in Albert doesn't know what net
points are he's got your points Albert
actually do ya get a chance to meet dr.
Wecht Albert no I I worked on this for I
met Peter about four months before when
he was writing and
liked the part and I certainly like the
subject and I worked on the character I
worked on it with Peter Cyril Wecht is
available on YouTube because he's a
famous lecturer he was the preeminent
guy who was who just he didn't believe
in the one bullet theory with JFK he was
the big guy who said look at JonBenet
Ramsey's father he was been this
prominent a speaker and so he's all over
YouTube so he's easy to study and then
you have to deal with the words that are
written when I got to Pittsburgh then
night before what my first day of
shooting I get this call do you want to
have dinner with Cyril Wecht and I said
no if a hunchback German walks in I'm
done you know I can't already perfected
a character I like to see you you know I
wouldn't be able to do it so I never met
him
but I felt like I knew him and given his
profession I hope I never do meet him
David I want to ask you about the
violence I won't talk about Mike
Webster's hands they're very prominent
to film even for a fleeting moment they
look like hands that have gone through a
meat grinder I mean they're horrible
hands and I guess that's emblematic of
the condition of his body
you talk a little bit about just his
hands and how he even created that on
film we did four and a half hours of
makeup every day started three o'clock
in the morning hands are a big part of
it you know I watched his his Hall of
Fame speech over and over again and and
they were a big part of it every time he
grabs somebody you know every single
play of his career he was the center
being grabbed grabbing he broke his
fingers hands over and over again
he supposedly had no concussions which
you know is impossible I've talked to
players who who've had a few recorded
concussions but they'll tell you they've
had you know five times that
but those hands at his feet - if you saw
pictures of his feet but at the end of
his life he literally was out living in
the snow
in a pair of pants with just a pair of
pants no shoes no shirt a blanket he'd
be out there for days when he was
homeless walking around I mean his body
he tased himself to go to sleep I'm
sorry he tased himself to go to sleep he
literally he would he was huffing
ammonia at the end of his life to keep
himself awake because he was afraid he
would die if he went to sleep and then
he would use the tasers to knock himself
out because he was so exhausted because
he couldn't get the drugs that he needed
and that's pretty much how he ended his
life you know we didn't spend a lot of
time talking or worrying over the NFL
because it was a story one the story has
been broken that they had already had a
concussion settlement it's the story of
this one gentleman this one doctor and
it wasn't the intention of it wasn't to
sort of go after the NFL but was to tell
this story
we were sensitive to the truth of the
story like you are in any narrative
nonfiction movie but we didn't do a lot
of hand wringing over what the future of
the movie was going to be while we were
planning to make the movie mitai men we
would hear like oh will we be able to
buy a spot on network television it's
like well that would be a its own story
if somebody stopped us from buying a
spot on network television for a movie
so no we didn't spend a lot of time on
that you don't want to ask a little bit
this is film is loosely adapted from a
GQ article what did the GQ article give
you narrative lay that history hadn't
you know it's a brilliant piece 2009 was
just before Dave Duerson killed himself
which happened the film and a couple
years before junior sayo killed himself
jean-marie alaska's who's a fantastic
journalist was able to synthesize what
was
clearly an epidemic of football players
dying violently not just killing
themselves sometimes killing their
families not just men in their 40s and
50s sometimes teenagers and men in their
20s and it was an epidemic that was
happening all over the country but
nobody was watching it because these
were men who would slip into a cave and
vanish without a word jean-marie really
started to synthesize and put it
together but it was until she met
Bennett that she had you know I used to
be a journalist and in journalism
there's a phrase that we all have that
we all hope for it's called the holy
[ __ ] moment you know you could be
reporting on a story for weeks or months
and until you get to that moment where
you're like holy [ __ ] like that's the
story and she had it and it was a really
it was a it was a fantastic launching
off that was my moment when I saw my
deal that was my moment when I knew I
was gonna get to work with you Albert me
and my band we went and saw the movie
out in London and first you know I was I
felt kind of cool you know seeing the
movie four comes out but um yeah I mean
just totally inspired by you know the
story I mean Will Smith could act in a
movie about potatoes and it'd be great
Will Smith is mr. Potato Head
Christmas 2017 I think it's in
development but you know and so I didn't
want to make a song that was you know
literal literal you know so literal to
the story you know and so the song so
long it comes from a personal thing you
know just me going back you know people
back home saying that you know I don't
deserve to be where I'm at because you
know I haven't worked as hard or long as
you know some musicians who's been doing
it longer you know and so it's like he's
saying that I love where I'm from but
maybe I need to leave because you know
I'm not feeling too loved were you
shooting during the NFL season yeah we
started shooting at the end of October
right doesn't like being in Pittsburgh
during the NFL see I mean everybody I
mean you see extras wearing jerseys I
that's not that's real
right wilai jerseys yeah everybody in
the whole city wears a jersey on a
Sunday yeah it was you know the black
and gold is real in in Pittsburgh you
know so you know I think it added and an
extra we knew what we had to do and it
definitely gave us an authenticity and I
like that we're mission eyes dive never
used that before I'm going to start
using it but it was that you know we
were we were mission eyes and I wouldn't
use them don't use you know but actually
being in Pittsburgh it was was really
heavy in a lot of ways the we were
shooting in a lot of the places where
you know some of the actual scenes
occurred the the the woman for example
there it's a brief moment when the
slides are being made for Mike Webster's
brain samples and we use the actual
woman who did the original
brain samples so there was a lot of that
as an actors really it was heavy but it
kept you completely grounded and
completely focused and and clear about
the the the honesty and depth and truth
of what you were trying to portray we
don't really know what's gonna happen in
terms of the NFL and football and the
impact of this movie the NFL football is
the largest spectacle in the history of
man it is hugely wealthy it's the
richest sport in the world it's the
most-watched sport in the world the the
Super Bowl last year was the
most-watched thing on television in
history and is only getting bigger
weirdly while this kind of iceberg is
off in the distance you know this movie
the subject matter coming close and so
we don't know what happens when this
massive juggernaut collides with a very
simple truth so that being said you know
I play football through two years
College and I loved watching the game
it's graceful it's beautiful and I
didn't make a decision to stop watching
football I just have found myself
drifting away from the television when
it's owned in my house my son played at
Oakes Christian so it was almost the
most fun I've ever had as a parent was
watching that kid catch that football
and it was it was never even a subject
you know you we were worried you know we
worried if he would break his leg we
were the big thing was spinal injury
that was what all the parents were
talking about is his spinal injury so
the idea that there was a possibility of
long-term brain damage was was never a
question so I felt like you know as a
parent I had to make this film just for
people to know I've had a minimum we
have to know and then you can make a
decision so with that I was asked a
question what would I you know if with
the information I have and we're back to
my son being 14 years old and he wants
to play and you know I said that's
that's a that's a really difficult
question at 14 your kids are invincible
all right so the you know to sit him
down and say well son let let's discuss
chronic traumatic encephalopathy you
know it just it would be very very
difficult for me to demand that he not
play a game that he loved I would give
him all of the information we would go
through we would he would understand
everything that was happening and I just
the my style of parenting I would have
to make the decision with him